I got an ultrasound on my right axilla axillary area because I felt the lump in it turned out to be residual
cerebral from the surgery. They also noted this multiple morphological benign lymph nodes.
We're noted in the right axilla within cortices and fatty hyla. What I scanned my left side or comparison,
they found this comparative imaging on the left axilla demonstrates two adjacent abnormal lymph nodes with
thickened cortices measured up to four millimeters. Now they want to do a biopsy of one of these.
Would these be due after surgery? I don't know if they were there when they clipped the large lymph
nodes before surgery. Does this mean if the biopsy is positive that my current program is not helping
stop recurrence? I am supposed to get my implant surgery in January 8. Can I ask them to just
remove those two lymph nodes while they're there? I just got this information yesterday. I'm not
spoken with my oncologist or my surgeon yet. I don't know what to do with this new information,
thoughts. Well, let's do this question first. Just got this information. I haven't spoken to them yet.
So, you need to talk to your doctor about whether they can remove those lymph nodes.
They may push hard for getting a biopsy to see what they are first
and then if they because the truth is that if from their standpoint, if these are cancerous,
they're not going to want to do this implant surgery. I don't think that might be off the table if
these are cancerous. They'll be pushing hard for radiation or something like that.
So, we just don't know yet. As far as this question, does this mean if the biopsy is positive
the my current program, I think you're talking about your nutrition, your diet, your right,
is not helping stop reoccurrence? This is a common thought in people's mind. Because by cancers
getting worse, does it mean everything I'm doing just didn't work? Well, the answer is,
yes, in a way, it didn't work the way you wanted it to work, meaning it didn't make all your cancer
go away and you don't have any problem right now. But the truth is is that if you weren't doing
everything you were doing, the truth is you could have been dead six months ago. I mean, you just don't
know that. You don't know how well everything you're doing is holding things at bay
for as long as it possibly can. There's only the bottom lies. There's only so much human
control you have over your life. I know we all want to feel especially those that live in America,
feel like we have full control over our destiny and that if we just make changes that we can
change our destiny, I'll guarantee you just in time that I spent as a missionary in Mexico where there
was just an utter, we're working with just the destitute impoverished people. They didn't come from
the feeling and the background that they could change their current situation by making a few different
decisions in life. There was some things that they just couldn't change. I mean, there was just,
you know, almost an impossibility of getting out of their situations. But we in America think that
because we have had such affluence and because we're taught to be relatively narcissistic in our
philosophy, even in our churches, that we have control over our destiny. And to a certain extent,
we do. We were given free will. We can choose our diet. We can choose our lifestyle. We can choose our
partner. We can choose a lot of things. But God constantly reminds us that we can't choose everything.
You can't choose whether your heart's going to continue to beat or not even if you do everything
right. I can't tell you how many people I talk to on a weekly basis that's saying things like,
I just can't believe I got cancer. I've been living this, you know, we've been only eating organic
for 20 years. We've been doing, you know, filling the blank. And you think that because you're doing
good things, right? Not arguing that eating correctly and taking good nutrition and doing making good
lifestyle choices are probably going to give you better outcomes than if you did otherwise.
But it doesn't mean that we're going to be, you know, immune from heart disease or, you know,
cancer or vascular problems or a stroke or, you know, getting run over by a train. So
things happen that are beyond our control. We live in a fallen world. And you do everything.
I believe that from the, from a biblical perspective, we're supposed to do everything we can do
to an extent. If we become obsessed with getting our way, whether our way is to be cured of a
disease or our way is to be financially independent, or our way is to be rich or wealthy,
or our way is to have the perfect relationships or our way is filling the bank. What is it that you
want in life? Well, we've been programmed and conditioned to get what we want and to fight for
and, and, you know, make goals of achieving that which we want. And in one sense, you can say that's
a noble achievement. But in other sense, we have to be very careful that we don't step
over that line into a galletry and self-indulgence and complete darsacistic behavior
and being obsessively compulsive about our self and our darsacistic thoughts.
Um, that's something especially Americans more than other people have to fight against. If you talk
about your, your daily fight against your flesh that the Apostle Paul spoke about, he probably didn't
have in the first century. Christians didn't have the same fight that we have as Americans.
We live in affluence and we are stricken with affluenza and thinking that we get our way all the time.
And I'm not saying everybody's on this call because you want to get rid of your cancer,
you want to get healthy and what the heck are you a doctor for if you're saying that you don't have
control of these things. I'm saying you do everything you possibly can without becoming
obsessive about it. You do everything you possibly can. Ultimately, you have to leave their
results to God. And ultimately, everything that happens to us is supposed to, if we're believers,
we claim to be believers. It's supposed to drive us to a deeper relationship with him.
Otherwise, what, what, what is there a reason for living but other than to glorify God
and to express his kingdom on earth through our love for other people. And, and for me at least,
I'll just speak for myself. I have to die to myself on a daily basis and die to my desires
and die to my wants. If my cancer comes back, I'm going to be very disappointed. But then I have to
is a mature believer get over that pretty quick. Are there some things I need to change to get back
on my diet probably and doing the more right things? Yes. But if my cancer continues to progress
in it, and I'm going to continue downhill and tell my death, then, you know, I have to accept that
and bring him glory through that. And that's a, I'm not saying it's not, it's, it's not going to,
it's not hard. But I'm just saying that that is really the good fight that we all must strive for.
And that is the good life that that we that we need to aim for. That's the goal we need to aim for
is to hear, well done, good and faithful servant. We're done with this with this path.
I'm not talking directly to this person. Everybody just wants to get better. I'm talking to myself
more than anything else. So I don't think I'm, I'm, you know, harping on anybody here. So I'm
harping on myself. And it's a reminder that that that that's that's our good fight that we have to
work on every day. It's dying to ourself. Yes, do everything we can do. But then we,
we ultimately have to surrender to, okay, this is not a mind way. It's God's way. He's got to play
out of this. Okay, I break him glory through it.